Tianna is with us in California ha Tiana
how are you good to talk to you so much
for everything
thank you what can I help with well I'm
a mom I've been living with my mom for
the last couple of years and recovering
from some of my own stupid mistakes and
in the process of doing a little bit
better from financially I've taken on
some of my mom's that as well because of
sharing the home so she has in she's in
a chapter 13 bankruptcy and with only
about nine months left on the payment
plans and and then there's like the HOA
payment and we're coming out to be about
with her social security and my income
we're coming out short about six hundred
six to eight hundred dollars a month and
it's been I've been juggling like
sometimes I short pay my car payment so
that I can pay you know one of those
other bills like these what do you make
a year I make about 35 to 38 with
overtime everyone that's do you have
student loan about 10 grand and my car
and then how much did you owe in your
car
about 9 grand hmm okay so 19,000 and you
make 38,000 a year and then there's
about seven or so no helmets exactly but
there's there's probably about between
five and seven thousand on credit card
stuff okay so if you were out of debt
and on your own how much debt does your
mother's in a chapter 13 coming out
which means that that will all be clear
in nine months has she got any debt
other than what's in the chapter 13 well
okay and how much is her house payment
in the 13 it is it's three hundred and
twenty four thousand okay and so she's
paying a house payment of how much
about 1,400 and what is her income 1,200
a month okay and how old is she okay she
can't live in that house anymore
okay you can't have a $1,400 house
payment with a $1,200 income okay it
doesn't work what that means is you have
to live there until she's 90 and pay her
house payment that's not gonna work hey
this is a really really bad plan I don't
know how she got into this mess but so
when she comes out the chapter 13
bankruptcy her house payment will be
$1,400 a month it should be less there's
an extra Chi didn't pay property tax so
there it should be 1200 but they're
charging 200 extra a month for the back
payments her income is 1200 exactly yeah
so does she have any money anywhere now
she's in chapter 13 and she doesn't have
anything she owns right other than this
house what's the house worth it's
actually worth there they came in and
said that it could be worth about six
hundred thousand but she just
I've been training to sell and we're
trying to look at it we might look at it
again after the chapter thirteen over we
I talked to her about downsizing because
we've been listening to your show and
and so I'm trying to get out of the
situation and here's what I want I want
you to be in your mother's life and
loving her well but I don't want you to
design a financial plan that requires
that you live together the rest of your
life right that's a bad plan would you
agree yes okay so let's try to let's try
to develop a plan for her and a plan for
you and if the plan to get to those
things is accelerated by you temper
surely being together that's fine but I
don't want to put together a thing where
you're dependent upon each other for
your plans to work she needs to sell the
house and buy a $300,000 paid-for condo
that she can live in and that means
you're out on your own at that point and
we're gonna get your income up and cut
up your credit cards we're gonna put you
into Financial Peace University I'm
gonna pay for it and look you completely
out of debt because you've got a bunch
of debt and not a lot of income for
Orange County California I agreed right
I have a certification coming up that's
my employer agreed to pay for it so I
should be making more good what are you
getting your cert in I'm in certified
professional coders good so you're doing
China you're doing technical doing
technical stuff and you're getting your
certifications around that right right
you good you keep doing that you keep
doing that as fast as you can do it and
get as many of those as you can get and
keep getting those raises because that's
going to cause your income to double in
the next three years if you keep pushing
on that this is just the first
certification you want you to get then I
want you to go get some more of them and
keep your employer paying for them and
keep growing and growing and growing and
growing because that's going to solve
your problem that's very good news okay
now if you guys want to stay there for
the next nine months and tell you she
comes out of the 13 and then she sells
and that helps you get out of debt
that's fine but it sounds to me like you
you would be better off and she would be
better off if she sold it now we only
talked to one but and he was saying it
could be complicated not impossible with
the chapter 13 you need a realtor it's
not a big deal chapter 13 stake payoff
letters every day as soon as you get
them as soon as you get a closing and
you got a $600,000 check in your hand to
pay off a $300,000 loan that's really
not rocket science okay it can be done
so here's it because otherwise you are
going to be paying
like 600 700 bucks out of your pocket in
order to live there right right I don't
know it sounds like it's expensive to me
I mean maybe you want to pull that off
maybe you want to work an extra job in
order to do that for nine months and
then sell it it's okay you can do either
one but really a year from today y'all
aren't don't need to be living together
this is not good for either one of you
are you catching on yeah and not because
I don't love your mother and you don't
love your mother we want her to be taken
care of we want you to be taken care of
but this thing this thing of joining
together and staying in denial about
this house is a bad plan this house is
gone she can't afford it
you can't have a 1400 or a $1,200 house
payment when you're how income is $1,200
I mean know everyone knows that so and
now you do so now everyone does so now
get her sold and then get you a place
and get your income up and you work your
debt snowball hold on I let Kelly pick
up I'll put you in the Financial Peace
University we'll help you on your
journey because you've got a difficult
one for the next 12 months after that
it's going to get better and better and
better and better and better and better
cut up your credit cards today all of
them it's time for plastic surgery you
cannot live on that around there anymore
this is a family trait that needs to be
broken today
hope that helps you kiddo you call me if
I can help you that's what we're here
for this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]